Um,
I think it may have something to do with
the
myths of the gala to at least the ideal
of Galitary aneurysm,
um,
that,
uh,
it's better to be a regular guy.
I'm with sort of good standing in the
community,
good character and so on than to be a,
an egghead eggheads,
uh,
a suspected.
And that's not just American culture.
I think that's,
that was true traditionally in,
in,
in Britain as well.
And there's something to be said for it.
I mean,
there are,
there many unpleasant,
uh,
effects of,
of that kind of fillets,
Philistinism.
But the good thing is that ideas can be
dangerous.
Intellectuals are dangerous where you
give them too much power because they
tend to take ideas to their extreme and
uh,
they're not practical people in the
whole.
Um,
and it's good,
I think to be a little suspicious of
taking idea,
any idea to its extreme and it's
probably better to have people in power
who are more practical and who can,
who know the art of compromise.
Well,
I think he would be,
on the one hand,
probably a shocked because some of his,
um,
possibly some of his is worse,
his most pessimistic predictions would
seem to have come true and that he,
he,
he was on the one hand in favor of
democracy and he admired American
democracy,
but he was frightened of the possible
consequences.
He thought it could lead to tremendous
vulgarity and so on.
And I think he probably would see that
and you would also see a much less a
conformist population probably than the
one he saw,
depending on where he would travel,
of course.
Um,
and I think he probably would be rather
shocked by the tone of the public
figures of the politicians who are
probably less little less high minded
than the ones that he encountered when
he was there.